any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable in magic
welcome everybody to the into the
impossible podcast the production of the
arthur c clarke center for human
imagination at the University of
California San Diego I am professor
Bryan Keating professor of physics and
co-director of the arthur c-- clark
center i always say and frequent
listeners will know this that this is a
politics free zone
that I never like to have politics
really enter in to our discussions here
because I believe very deeply that human
beings need a place that's less free of
politics and actually to have a respite
from it
and yet I think it's also important to
realize as I've often said you know the
reason I became an astronomer is because
there's no Democrat constellation over
there and a Republican comet coming over
there instead we're all human beings
we're all citizens of this giant planet
floating through space it's quite
remarkable but in so doing I do
recognize that that political events can
influence how various aspects of the
human imagination can be enhanced and
promoted and one of those is politically
and and starting with the notion that
all politics is local
besides the politics of the Faculty Club
which I am not at liberty to discuss I
wanted to bring on two of the top
mayoral candidates for San Diego's
election of our next mayor in 2020
November 2020 and one of them is joining
me today and her name is Barbara Brie
and I've known Barbara for several years
and and she has very interesting history
in San Diego and I thought maybe we
believed begin by just you know stating
what your history is Barbara and first
of all thank you so much for joining us
and welcome to the into the impossible
podcast thank you thank you Brian well
first of all I'm very happy to be in a
politics free zone for 30 minutes and I
think as you know I'm not a career
politician I I've had a long and varied
and diverse career starting with being a
journalist working at an
entrepreneurship center at UCSD for ten
years
at the connect program when it was still
at UCSD and then becoming an
entrepreneur in my own right and helping
to start several local
successful companies and running for
public office in 2016 for the San Diego
City Council so I came to an elected
office after they're a very diverse
background and you know I'm a mom I'm a
grandma I was the team manager for my
two daughters Bobby sucks softball teams
and all of these all of these
experiences have informed who I am
wonderful and yeah I like that the
notion that you can be more than just
your job of course you know a lot of
times when people feel the so defined by
their job and and and yet there's so
many things that we are beyond what we
do for a living and it's always nice to
delve into those topics and the ultimate
issues of life and and kind of how they
can go from here of course you're
running for you know one of the highest
offices and in the state which would be
the mayor of our of our lovely city of
San Diego and I transplant here
originally from the East Coast but I
have no intents of leaving intention of
leaving and I fortunate to live and work
at the you know most most illustrious
University I can imagine UC San Diego
where we really pursue a cutting-edge
vision of what the future can be like
and our motto is kind of you know
embracing non tradition and and how we
see our contributions as scholars and
humanities and arts and in the sciences
and technology and benefiting San Diego
so what I thought I would do with you
and Todd Gloria is bring you guys on and
allow you guys to kind of express some
of your your visions or you know what
you would do if successful in your
campaign to to strengthen San Diego's
already prominent position in really
three different areas so I would say and
these are only limited to they're by no
means exhaustive it's just my
simple-minded way of focusing on things
that are extremely important to me
personally and you know since I'm the
host I can exercise my prerogative here
and those three areas will be education
and healthcare research and technology
and that can include transportation and
biotech and
and high-tech communications etc and
then lastly will be in entertainment and
sports and these are the things you know
I think that can make your life better
and it can make you enrich education and
entertainment etc and also can improve
the quality of your life and technology
transportation and basic research which
is what I do so maybe we'll start with
education can you say something about
what education means to you and where
you see the mayor having an influence on
the direction that San Diego takes with
respect to education so first of all
UCSD where you're a very prestigious
professor has is really the economic
engine of this region if there were no
UCSD there would be no Qualcomm we would
not have a thriving biotech center and I
spent 10 years at UCSD at the connect
program where I was the associate
director working to help start high-tech
and biotech companies and I often say
back in 86 when I joined connect I could
have counted the number of life science
companies on two hands and now there are
hundreds and there's industries I never
dreamed of precision medicine bio algae
cybersecurity you know things we didn't
even dream of back then and education is
really the key to this region's future
and it's educating our young people who
are growing up here to make sure they're
going to have access to the jobs in the
innovation economy which are the high
paying jobs and the service sector jobs
that they create around them and young
people growing up south of Interstate
eight are now at a major disadvantage in
terms of having the educational
opportunity to have the skills to access
these jobs and I have this is an issue I
have been thinking about long before I
ran for City Council and mayor as mayor
though I will have a school engagement
coordinator in my office who will work
with employers an employer could be UCS
D sharp Hospital the military ASD GE the
Old Globe Theater the of the San Diego
Padres
and work to develop relationships
between employers and schools so that as
kids grow up they understand the
opportunities that are available to them
and as they get older they get access to
paid internships right you came from the
East Coast I also came from the East
Coast I grew up in Philadelphia but most
of our future growth is going to come
from the kids who are growing up here
today so I'm blessed my husband Neal and
I each brought two children to our
marriage our children are all in their
30s they're all married
fortunately they all married people we
like and we never have Lessing yeah now
and now and that's the growth three of
our four children live here with their
spouses and we have three grandchildren
here so far this is the growth of San
Diego and it's our children and our
grandchildren who we need to make sure
have the education to fulfill the jobs
of today and tomorrow yeah that's that's
very very important obviously and along
with that is I think access you brought
up access to education what about access
to health care and the ways that San
Diego is uniquely positioned to both
broaden and democratize if you will
access to health care but also to
innovate in health care and is there
something does the mayor does he or she
have the power to really change course
or really further democratize both
health care and education
so the mayor doesn't directly control
either we have actually within the city
of San Diego many school districts San
Diego Unified being the largest but if
you live in Carmel Valley there are
other school districts if you live in
parts of the South Bay there are other
school districts so the mayor doesn't
directly control education but my school
engagement coordinator position is a way
to work with the schools to work with
the community colleges and and the
universities health care again the city
does not have direct control the county
and as on people don't usually
understand the differences between the
city and the county the county is the
healthcare agency for the entire
region it gets federal and state money
to provide mental health and physical
health services but what one thing we've
realized from this coronavirus pandemic
is we have a major public health problem
over half of san diego's have an
underlying health condition and it is
those people who are the most vulnerable
to dying from coronavirus and so we have
a major public health issue into and we
need to work the city in the county
together to make our children and all of
us healthier that the role the mayor can
play in that is more of a bully pulpit
mm-hmm but not a direct role with a
specific budget with a command that's
already I make yeah I like the idea that
you mentioned already of this engagement
officer and that was actually a question
I was going to ask both you and Todd
Gloria which is you know would you
consider a scientific adviser as part of
the mayoral off.not not me I'm fully
booked Gavin Newsom will be listening to
this I don't want it that's my ultimate
boss right everyone Janet Napolitano
please I'm not I'm not seeking another
job don't worry but I think you know
especially the kovat pandemic has really
highlighted the need for rapid
Diagnostics for mathematical modeling
for scientific coordination and you know
my fellow scientists are great but but
you know it's not really in our skill
set to really be political necessarily I
mean we have political opinions but
would something like that be in the
purview I'm not asking if you're going
to nucleate this position right now on
this program but but is that something
in the purview of a mayor to establish
an Office of Science and Technology
Policy you know within the mayoral
office to coordinate these vast assets
that we have here and say yes and so you
know I've lived in the innovation
economy world for 30 years and it's a
world that has not had a lot of
interaction with City Hall and we have
the this local government has not tapped
the expertise we have at UCSD at
research institutes in it you know tech
and biotech companies throughout the
region and as mayor I actually plan to
have
I would say a dollar a year people in
the mayor's office who will take a year
or so off from their full-time job and
come and help the city starting with how
we can use technology better to interact
with our residents and provide city
servant using technology to provide city
services better mm-hmm and do you see
growth as I see us you're challenged as
all cities are nowadays but also
benefiting from this wonderful human
capital that we have the wonderful
physical beauty that we have here in San
Diego I mean I think whoever becomes
mayor it's it's one of the best jobs in
the world in a certain sense I mean I
think the best job is San Diego weather
you know weather forecaster because it's
you know it's not so hard
and I always say the worst job is of
course sportscaster but we're not gonna
get into that
except maybe to say do you think that
our cultural our you know sports our
entertainment industry our tourism
industry
what role does that have to play in our
economy is it just a byproduct of our
you know winning the geographic a lot of
lottery how we how will you as mayor
make use of these assets that we have
here the natural resources entertainment
sports etc to better the lives of our
citizens yeah so first of all you know I
I spent 30 years in the business world
before that I was a journalist and I
stepped back and I looked at what are
San Diego's competitive strengths and
what are our weaknesses in terms of
attracting and retaining talent because
at the end of the day it's all about the
talent and so I say our beautiful
natural environment is one of our
competitive strengths you know our
beaches bays canyons oceans hiking
trails that's a competitive strength of
the fact that you can do outdoor sports
you know almost every day of the year
that's a competitive strength our
vibrant arts community you know when it
returns we have world-class theater in
San Diego we have a great opera we have
beautiful art galleries we have many
neighborhood community art groups this
is a competitive strength and as I
talked to employers they tell me that
these assets are what allows them to
attract and retain
so as mayor and I have been personally
engaged in the arts throughout my whole
life my husband and I we particularly
loved theater so we have season tickets
to the old globe the La Jolla Playhouse
in the San Diego wrap and ensuring the
success of all of these worlds is a key
part of what makes San Diego so special
and as mayor I want to make sure that
you know that we maintain you know
maintain our beautiful natural
environment that we maintain a thriving
arts community that's really important
so I had on a visionary thinker an
advisor to the arthur c clarke center by
the name of dr. peter diamandis a few
months ago and he has a series of books
I call him the most optimistic pessimist
or the most pessimistic optimist I've
ever met because it's all about the
power of exponential growth to kind of
flatten out and democratize scale
digitize our world and unfortunately you
know his book came out during the kovat
pandemic and unfortunately it kind of
begins with a little bit of a pay on to
cities and and transportation etc and
and his view that and I say unfortunate
just because I think a lot of the
vectors that made Cove it so so deadly
on the East Coast at least and maybe in
Northern California too or even in LA
was you know kind of the density
population and how that contributes to
the spreading of this awful pandemic but
but I do want to talk about that the
transportation system he views that as
sort of a dinosaur of a bygone age and
that will become what much more
individualized and you'll have personal
hovercraft or you know helicopters uber
or helicopters taking you around you
know right now in our city you're at
least known for your stance on micro
so-called micro mobility devices etc
what about that what about the trolley
system and and micro mobility where do
you see the future of transportation and
do you think has has Cova changed your
opinion in any way as to you know these
vectors for you know potential dis
distribution of negative aspects of
disease or of social viruses
as you know people are you know we've
had problems with with unrest obviously
and in recent months and and wanting to
understand online etc how to how to
perhaps do a better job of may of
maintaining the flow of you know in an
orderly fashion so first let me I know
it's a little rambling but let's talk
about transportation where do you see is
the future of San Diego transportation
where do these things fit in so when I
was running for City Council in 2016 I
would get asked a lot about traffic
congestion and what what should we be
doing to deal with it and as one of the
ways I would always talk about what more
people could work remotely and then what
happens is we have this terrible
pandemic and it turns out that many of
us can work very effectively remotely
more than we ever expected and many
people want to continue working remotely
when the world gets back to normal maybe
it won't be five days a week but it'll
be a majority of the time and we've seen
that we have fewer cars on the road and
we have cleaner air so I think about
ways we can reduce congestion and what
that's and what sort of a new a new
transportation network should look like
the trolley of that connects downtown to
UTC is almost completed cost several
billion dollars most of it paid for with
federal money and I think it's going to
be very important in on one of the most
congested routes you know i interstate
five getting people out of their cars
the key is the first mile and last mile
solutions of the the last mile well the
northernmost part is in my council
district I'm very pleased to have been
working from the time I got to Council
with the major employers to figure out
what kind of tram service shuttles
eventually autonomous vehicles will take
people where they need to go and
actually the Void station which is right
between UCSD and Scripps hospitals is
being designed so that autonomous
vehicles will be able to line up there
and people will be able to get in so
what one could be labeled UCSD library
and you would get in and it would scoot
you right off to the library another
could say UCSD engineering building and
it would take you to there and so I'm
looking at I think I think Clark
actually has a lot of good ideas and I
think autonomous vehicles are going to
be very important I know that sand agar
regional transportation agency is
looking at an investment in more fixed
rail high-speed fixed rail I'm not sure
we're going to need to do that given
other trends like autonomous vehicles
that are coming along it is much less
expensive to use buses high-speed buses
because they're much more flexible we
can change the routes more easily as you
know we see transportation patterns
changing the pandemic also has offered
up a lot of opportunities as people more
people are going to work remotely
we may have empty office space we may
have empty office buildings retail that
many retailers are not going to be back
in business we may have shopping centers
that are sitting empty all of this is
going to provide opportunities for reuse
as housing and they are this is in
locations where there is already
infrastructure so I think the whole
world is going to change in many ways
because of this pandemic and I think we
have to relook at everything we thought
was going to work in the past mm-hmm yes
exactly and I think you know in terms of
technology it's a double-edged sword and
I wonder just in the last question
before we get to the final three
questions that I ask all my guess if you
see technology being threatened
threatening force for democracy itself
do you see it being being you know a
promotion of democracy I I don't mean
politically like this party uses these
Facebook ads but just technology is in
general I feel in some ways we retreat
to our bubble chambers and we're we're
more and more insulated even though
we've expanded our network exponentially
how to view technology is it a fun
mentally pro-democratic force small D
what's your what's your feeling about
the impact of technology on our
democracy it can be both good and bad so
as the pandemic hit of we've all been
forced to shelter in place for safety
reasons and we're using technology you
know here we are on as using zoom which
I had only used a few times before and
now I'm using zoom several hours a day
and Microsoft teams and other kinds of
methods to communicate with people so
technology can be a good thing but it
can also be misused like when people use
try to use technology to fix an election
that's a bad thing
it can also be a bad thing if we just
hide behind technology and don't have
you know human to human interaction so
but in terms of what has also been
interesting to see is how technology can
be used by local government to allow for
more reticent resident participation so
it in the old days before the pandemic
if you wanted to come testify at a
hearing at the city hall at City Hall
about it something we were discussing
you had to come in person to City Hall
well that's inconvenient you had to come
downtown either on public transportation
or you drove and then you had to pay for
parking right now the City Council we
give people the council members the
option of either meeting remotely or
coming in person but the public is
excluded for public safety reasons and
they are allowed to participate by phone
so they don't have to go anywhere
that's much makes participation much
easier so I think even after we go back
to the way we were people should still
be allowed to participate by phone
Community Planning meetings are now
happening over zoom and many people are
saying I want to have that option you
know three months from now because it
may be easier for me I would have needed
a babysitter so I couldn't have gone to
the University City Community Plan
Update meeting but this way I can be at
home and participate so I think you know
I see some good things right yeah
somebody said online
you know thank God this didn't happen
before Netflix because they would not
have survived okay so now I'm gonna
start what I call the final five which
is really it won't take that long
hopefully these are questions I ask of
all my guests and it's kind of a little
way to get to know my listeners better
and they they have some either
connection to my book or to our through
C Clark and you'll understand that as we
go on so the first question that I ask
all my listeners is it really came to me
based on my book losing the Nobel Prize
thanks to Alfred Nobel who left a will
that endowed these most prestigious
prizes but also had a component that the
winners not only be you know make
brilliant contributions to physics for
example but also that they do so in the
betterment of all of humankind and so
that in Judaism is known as the sava
ethical will so not a material will
which he also wrote that's where he put
his money Alfred Nobel but an ethical
will so what kinds of values do you want
to most articulate to future generations
and I think you know nowadays it's it's
become a little bit common to do these
things you can even do them online I can
give links to them but what kinds of
wisdom would you most want to convey to
future generations not not necessarily
your own biological children
grandchildren etc but to the whole world
what values would you like to
communicate so a Brian like you I grew
up in a Jewish household and I grew up
with the values of sadaqa and tikkun
olam and I think they are universal
values and they those values have
influenced my whole life of to repair
the world and to leave the world a
better place than you find it very nice
so yes tikkun olam is improving the
world just for the few listeners that
might not be fluent in Aramaic and
Hebrew I we have a lot of them but and
then sadhakas charity our tithing and
that's very very nice to hear the next
question is kind of another question for
the future so I ask a couple questions
about the future the first one about the
ethical will second ones about what
object or material or knowledge would
you most want to
on your monolith now what's a monolith
it's not a monorail
it's a monolith and and you may remember
from arthur c clarke 2001 a space
odyssey that people find this monolith
this chunk of rock it's huge and it's
really left by a future or an ancient
civilization of spacefaring aliens in a
way to evoke messages to human beings
that they were intended to be found and
it sort of reminds me to ask you because
we are the arthur c-- clark center for
human imagination if you had a monolith
what sort of thing would you want to put
on it or in it as a billion year long
time capsule i so it's something
somebody would read in a billion year
billion years from now yes well it could
be an object it could be something that
that's representative of humankind or
you have some message for the future
time capsule like objects well i've
never been you know what this is really
I have never been asked this question
before exclusive you heard it here hope
we'll hear it here well I think it would
be a message not an object it would I
mean one of the messages that has driven
my life is that relentless pursuit will
get you further than good grades uh just
that just to to keep trying to not give
up which i think is a is something
unique to people that stands the test of
time disagree yeah so the last of these
kind of future and past ones actually is
a message to your former self and it
harkens to the name of our podcast which
is the into the impossible podcast you
may have heard my listeners certainly
have that arthur c clarke had many many
laws that he claimed were laws of nature
the first one being that any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic that was
let in law number one law number two
you'll probably like this in the
politics world he said for every expert
there's an equal and opposite expert
okay and the third law was the only way
to find out what is possible is to
journey out into the impossible and
that's of course the name of the podcast
so what I want to ask you is advice to
your former self we spent time going a
billion years in the future now let's go
a couple years in the past and ask you
what advice would you give to your 20
year old self about something that might
have seemed impossible to overcome but
somehow you were able to overcome it by
going into the impossible so I I'm 71
years old not when you're an elected
official no secrets about your age so I
grew up in a very different moment in
time I was blessed to have an
extraordinary mother Adelaide Bree and I
kept her last name in honor of her my
mother got divorced in the mid sixties
she went to work at a full time job
where she was paid less than the
comparable man there was nothing she
could do about it but she empowered me
to believe I could succeed in the
business world I've earned an MBA from
Harvard in 1976 at a time few women were
getting an MBA anywhere so I've spent my
life trying to go beyond what the world
around me found acceptable for most
women and I have never forgotten and I
always remember that I've been blessed
to have the success that I've had and my
life wasn't always easy my first
marriage ended in 93 I had two daughters
8 and 11 and we we we really my family
had very little money at that time my
ex-husband had been successful and had
lost everything mm-hmm so I've spent my
life trying to overcome many challenges
and I had never forgotten and I've
because of that I've spent a lot of my
life trying to empower other women in
particular started to organisations that
empower women Athena San Diego and run
women run and what I would tell my 20
year old self which my mother kind of
told me always is Barbara you can do it
believe in yourself don't feel you have
to be like everybody else that was one
the key mantras my mother gave me the
belief that I could be who I was I
didn't have to to fit in with everyone
else one thing I wish I had done back
then I was a sociology major as an
undergraduate at the University of
Pennsylvania I wish I'd majored in
computer science well we'd love to have
you here in the department sure computer
science and engineering
Barbara Bree most comes I end the
interview with what I call the plug zone
which I give you a chance to tell people
what you're working on next but I think
it's obvious what you're working on next
running for mayor of the glorious city
of San Diego can you tell people where
to find you online and how to
participate in your mission sure so I'm
Barbara Brie my last name is spelled Bri
and pronounced like the cheese our
website is Barbara breed comm you can
find me on twitter at breathe
ery for number for SD you can email me
at barbara at barbara breed comm and you
can call my cell phone at eight five
eight two four eight nine four six five
I'd be honored to talk with you I am NOT
your normal career politician and I'm
not beholding to the normal special
interest and Brian will probably not
meet let me do anymore
Jerry okay that's okay Barbara it's
always a treat to get to talk to you and
I've enjoyed this conversation immensely
I know my listener as well as well and
I'll keep you posted when we when we put
it up thank you for sharing I know your
time is so incredibly tight for you
thank you for being so generous and
gracious with your time thank you Brian
I hope to see you in person soon me too
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable imagine
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible please subscribe comment
share rate and review for a chance to
win a free copy of our most recent
guests newest book send a screenshot of
your review to info at imagine UCSD edu
we appreciate hearing from you that are
always open to your suggestions for
future episodes for more information go
to imagination dot UCSD edu find us on
twitter and imagine UCSD watch us on
youtube listen on itunes into the
impossible is a production for the
arthur c-- clark center for human
imagination in the division of physical
sciences at the University of California
San Diego
Eric veeery director Bryan Keating
co-director Patrick Coleman associate
director produced by Stewart Valco